- This is a $600 footstep.
- Shoes are the only article of clothing
I will spend significant money on.
Like, I'll spend like 80 to 100 bucks
on a pair of shoes if I
really, really like them.
- I usually just spend around
$100 on shoes, but that's it.
- I don't spend tons of money
on, like, any clothing items.
Once a shoe gets over
like 130, 150 it's like
it's not really on my radar.
- I don't really know
too much about shoes.
I wear boots.
That's pretty much all I do.
- Oh, I have these shoes.
- Oh yeah.
(laughing)
How much did I pay for these?
- Okay, okay.
I can hang with these.
- I do feel like there's genius marketing
to come up with these
barefoot based running shoes,
because way less material,
not as strong material,
and they can sell them for just as much.
- I would say like, from my experience,
this is probably $80.
- I was gonna say $80.
- If you say 79, I will...
- $79.
(sighing)
- I think these ones are like $60 shoes.
- A hundred.
- I literally have like
five pairs of these.
- Yeah, I just can't remember
how much I paid for it,
but I want to say a solid like 80, no 90.
- I feel like it's like 75.
(ringing)
- Yeah, what do you know?
(laughing)
- Wow, Kevin was way off.
You lost me.
- Yeah, I'm like, I don't know.
Like these are funky shoes.
- Oh!
- It looks like a boot and
a sneaker at the same time.
They look like mutated chucks.
- These almost remind me
of Spinelli, from Recess.
- Yeah, these are very much like,
only a cartoon character
would wear these shoes.
- It's like a Converse on steroids.
- Yeah, it's a Converse on steroids
mixed with, like, a bowling shoe.
- I'm gonna say 120.
- Aaah, 200!
- 125.
- 160.
- $135.
- 150.
- What?
- What!!?
- $1,085 for these shoes?
- Do we have to pay to
touch them like this?
Like is there like a $10 touching fee?
- It looks like skater
shoes from middle school.
- They're kinda like cool space shoes.
- They're very plain, but the
are simultaneously unique.
I've never seen a shoe that
looks like this before.
- After touching the
other shoe I'm just like,
I don't know, I'm very
confused on shoes now.
- They look like Adidas at
the top, but these just look
like bricks, like, these look
heavier than Air Force One.
- I'm gonna say 175.
Just because you're
paying for that height.
- I'm gonna take a risk, and say 30.
- 165.
- I'm gonna say 225.
- $50.
- I'm gonna high-ball these at about $300.
Geez, 555?
- And you were high-balling it.
- I was, I thought that
I was gonna be over.
- I would not have the stones
to make a pair of shoes
and be like, "yeah, here they
are world, that'll be $550".
- Whoa!
- This could be, like,
a 13 year old's shoe.
- These are ugly.
- I kinda like them.
- This could be like
a Lady Gaga shoe also.
- I'm gonna go out on a limb,
I'm gonna say that these shoes
are really expensive,
not because it's flashy,
but you're also getting a weapon.
- The inside looks like a luxury car.
- It also says "Paris" inside.
- Oh shoot, alright, easily over $1,000.
- Oh wait, okay these are all plastic.
And they're ch... $45.
- I'm gonna say like 65.
Is it $65?
- I think these are like,
the costume jewelry of shoes.
- I'm gonna just hope that at
least one of these is cheap,
and call this 110 bucks.
- I'm gonna say these are $800.
- 5,000
- Dude, that is, that's a car.
I'm gonna go later, I'm gonna say 500.
- My tactic was slightly
off, just by a smidge.
- I think that's how much I paid
for my down payment on my car.
- These are the kind of
shoes that you only know
are that expensive if
you're a sneaker-head.
Like, who are you trying to
impress with these shoes?
- For me, the joy of buying
anything is the value.
And the value is how cool
it is, divided by the price.
So I will never be proud of something
that is that expensive.